dude I had a guy one time I go in there
in the bathroom right they got a guy in
there is like right when I go in there
we're doing number two it's stressful
bro he goes I got your back bro yeah
there's no terminal for spare you just
kind of show up
it's kinda like who's flying spirit and
you raise your hand like I get on the
plane yeah and you're in a lawn chair
yeah it was hectic pilots are usually in
shorts and sandals yeah it's a wave I
felt too loosey-goosey
at one point the pilot was just like in
the middle of just like practicing with
a golf club
[Laughter]
this is bizarre I think it's just like
you know autopilot the whole time they
got flight attendants oh hell no no but
if you had something that everyone then
they would ring a bell and if you had
something that you needed you got 30
seconds to get up and give do anything
about going the bathroom there's no
bathroom they had I got two rows down
for me selling fresh eggs out of his
book I know there was still wet a little
I had one they were still a little damp
he's called the Greyhound of the sky but
greyhounds like come on dog weight that
I've taken a greyhound from Arizona to
Texas oh yeah sir heroes we listen you
want to pay $79.99 [ __ ] to wait her
fourth of July man would you do I just
close my eyes and picture two cool
[ __ ] fireworks because the government
shut down fireworks and people that's
crazy
yes I just closed my eyes not crazy I
watched Tom Cruise in fourth of July you
didn't yeah the movie fourth of July is
it good it's all right would you guys do
cat I ended up going to dinner with my
family they were in town last week for
my birthday my dad's birthday my
sister's graduation and fourth of July
goddamn a lot cat's birthday was last
Friday bro no yeah no oh yeah it was
Friday yeah last Friday dude
oh god no no that is cat is I would say
probably 20 years old you know 25 in
five Wow congratulations Thanks
did you ask for anything for your bday
no I never asked for anything do you did
they get you anything
dinner Wow you know after after 21 it's
kind of dinner what is it they for it
sounds like it's the put to Irish potato
famine or something that's you dinner
for your birthday honestly that's just
like your mom let around the house yeah
Kat's mom won't even let her now the
house her gift was seen daylight was it
fun was it in her fun yeah it was a lot
of fun we went to go grab some
Vietnamese food in Orange County
would you have I ended up eating wow
it's like a soup dish where the whole
family sits around this big pot you have
soup like dumplings and stuff yeah thank
you
directly from the pot you put it in a
bowl oh wow what's the Vietnamese
dessert sure is okay this is kind of
mochi brain but um we have this thing
called Jaya and it was always so weird
to me growing up and seeing people eat
beans as a savory dish Asians eat beans
as a sweet dish oh yeah Chinese moon
pies yes the Chinese moon pies are made
out of bean so you ate beans as dessert
being into WITSEC out your mom runs a
tight you have pinto beans for your
sweet tooth where we all add on the
bottom of the Titanic and there's those
Chinese moon pies I've had those right
there festival you know what it's an
acquired taste it is is it sweet some of
them are
they have different fillings depending
on what you get and they got this
chocolate that was your birthday cake uh
no I did not have getting very I've got
your bean pie for your birthday Mac oh
[ __ ]
gosh I wish I woulda known count oh we
got you one the ice cream cakes from
Dairy Queen oh well maybe next year yeah
milk will kill the Vietnamese there dude
or put us out for at least a day yeah
that's why they have to have very unique
type of stuff they got beans sugar yeah
you know they really dude your coconut
milk instead of regular melons yeah I
like that
did you uh they're more tree people
brother I got to eat stuff out of the
tree exactly out of the animal did you
um get yourself anything for your
birthday
no I never do anything for myself on my
birthday we think it sat on your
birthday
are you sat on my birthday my birthday
uh no it just kind of feels like any
other day nearly 25 yeah I think the
only news is that my boyfriend for the
past ten years didn't do anything for my
birthday why you guys were together yeah
what a piece of [ __ ] I think that's why
I like you set a precedence in my mind
really early that was like oh it's just
another day did you do anything for his
birthday I would take him out to dinner
he didn't like doing stuff either
and what's he on twitch he's brown
you're tick-tock yeah I can see that
damn so nothing on your beat a cat well
we didn't get you anything
no I hate to say that but we get most
like my ex-boyfriend yeah yeah we're in
it should I definitely know him because
you guys working together for years I
mean I think well I know it's her
birthday and you know I can still do
something he always texts me on my
birthday every year
I'll get kept on for a birthday I always
do that's sweet of you guys then I just
like dude I go by a different calendar
so her birthday is until this Friday
dude least have a bootleg calendar when
your mom got a cheaper calendar and it
was from like three or four years
earlier makes sense since everything was
like a little off you know
despite their - oh did I be waiting for
the bus for like six hours on a frickin
Saturday morning if you get a but you're
not a materialistic person cat if you
could have something for your be there
what would you want I mean I think if
cost wasn't a thing and time wasn't a
factor either I'd go on vacation
it's you a boyfriend eh Kim's trying to
save that money he wants somebody who
wants to stay more local yeah if I can
afford a trip to Hawaii
he was his local dream like wait I'm
going back to Burbank I'll get you an
uber to Burbank like going somewhere far
away Hong Kong or G Manor
what are you saying don't you miss not a
place for Chi Minh City is it is
Benihana sorry Theo of the bowling lane
that comes with that just open up the
nightclub that came with that warm
canned beer after box yeah there's not a
lot of people there because all he plays
is Nickelback I could see him playing
some gerald levert and that's your
little key sway sway little genuine boy
I could hear black Street playing all
night no doubt what was that one big
group was a guy with the hair Cisco the
fog kind of ruined him right he did the
song there's I know buddy so it was so
kind of raunchy I think it was over
after that ooh I got this shirt actually
for fourth of July along got me this
okay yeah is that from Express huh no
it's like a like a dinner shirt okay
yeah look so you can go an important
meeting you
we're not in a meeting but maybe like a
meeting for food for dinner yeah that's
nice I'm waiting I'm with my foods
getting deliveries be here any second oh
you got to get something snack up bruh
do I'm snacking up snacking all the time
oh you're so swings dog fill your holes
and fill your mouth get that a port
roast that port roast suppository don't
go deep nothing better than post mates
post place doesn't just deliver burgers
and sushi they actually make life easier
by picking up everything I need I'm
talking medicine from Walgreens maybe an
energy drink from 7-eleven they drop it
off outside my door all you got to do is
just download post mates the app on your
phone and get anything what delivered
within an hour eating you want you want
burger you won't fry you want a spicy
tuna roll for your stupid mouth you want
that spicy tuna roll baby you want
whatever you want a wrench you want some
post-it notes they got you some nyquil
dayquil yeah any any time quill bro
midnight snack you whale yeah bro you
want a real live quail you want that
game hen you know you want a British
accent you can do whatever you want mine
for a limited time post mates is given
our listeners 100 US dollars worth of
free deliberate credit for your first
seven days tell them tell them Vernon to
start your free deliveries download the
app and use code Kay 80s to zero to zero
that's code cats 2020 for $100 a free
delivery credit for your first seven
days when you download the post mates
app anything you need anytime you need
it post mates
man the world's changin bro change
now picture me rollin baby picture me
with shipstation
why shipstation when you're selling
online get a lot of orders out fast can
be tough shipping how do you keep track
shit-shit who gets what which shipping
carrier do you use and like in the best
rates that's why you need ships acecomm
take all the guesswork out I'm talking
the fast it's easier so it's affordable
way to imagine ship your order shipping
ship station makes it easy helps online
sellers of any size get orders out
quickly save money on shipping Kashi and
keep your customers happy no matter what
your selling Amazon Etsy your own
website fish ship station brings all
your orders in one simple tip on my back
making them really easy to manage from
any device even your cell phone ship
station works with all the major
carriers including USPS FedEx UPS even
Amazon
no wonder ship station number one choice
of online sellers and right now you king
the sting thoughts you guys can try ship
station free for 60 days when you use
code Kay ATS make sure your business is
ready to meet the demands of delivery
culture that's the culture we live in
get started at ship station comm today
we live in a gig economy get your
business going you get our discount go
to ship station dot-com then enter offer
code Kay ATS click on the microphone at
the top of the page and type in Kay ATS
ship station comm make ship happen oh
who's this little thick nugget Oh God
right here who's this little [ __ ]
thick tenderoni you don't think it could
be a filter is that he's using on this
yeah I know think when I see her brother
yeah good call man looks like an
Australia bean pies guts got a debate
club topic for you all right
go take a leak No are you mm-hmm yeah
meet you brother know what job thing
gang gang but I feel like we go by sound
brother probably the same problem I have
all you hear is your bread your
breathing
yeah I do the Ray Charles I just feel
things out here my breathing and I don't
trying to like because I don't want to
keep me up for a while and then I take
that hard SuperSoaker for you
oh I pee so hard in the night because I
drink so many fluids oh wow I'm never
not if you notice any show I do even at
home I'm never not drinking something
you're always having fluids always have
something my mouth like I've never runs
through it have you seen that movie yes
good movie I say I think it's fun to go
no light until you start to get a little
older and then it gets real risky going
to light yeah that's the part I find one
stray shoe I'm lazy you know I'll put
the take the shoes off and get right in
a bed there's no not a lot of middle
ground you know in between you know I'll
take the shoes off I'll have one of
those
peppermint York patty one of these
you're I'll be like I'm gonna brush my
teeth in the morning I'm gonna have this
tonight yeah and I'll get straight into
bed so then I get up in them on the
night I got to do urine and I don't it's
really it's a minefield cuz those shoes
are out there the pants you know you you
you want to take the road a little you
know you wanna make things difficult for
you
yeah it's so I don't do a ninja warrior
yeah you're getting a little more ninja
warrior and it's risky and sometimes
I'll I'll toe I'll just hold the line
bro you know I'm saying I'll just batten
down the hatch squeeze my wiener and go
back to sleep you never I pee hard
really it's then it's it's a nice
feeling
you little [ __ ] dog it's dummy I dumped
that bladder and it's loud I'm rod that
thing and just have a stressful [ __ ]
two more hours of sleep no painful
[ __ ] hours I like that full feeling
in my body that's not gay bro I guess a
water monitor I'd ride rain that thing
you do do i empty at all you sit down to
pee at night or Santa I stand up and I
always put my head in the wall see a
print on the wall what are you even see
a print because I died like this
mmm I'm like leaning like this I'm on my
tighty-whities what and I'm breathing
hard but that's that German style that's
like a black man at church do you
down oh you're on it I told you I Ray
Charles it yeah I can hear it
splattering on the kind of the top of
the lid so I got to pull it back oh yeah
yeah dad now once I get into the
bathroom then I use sound and know where
I'm P and if that's what he's talking
about don't know if he's talking about
getting to the toilet once I get there
though if I do have the lights off I
will pee for sound yeah I don't I don't
shoot the straight stream right off the
bat I do a little few drips and hit
listen for the sound oh really like oh
we good we clear the land and then I
[ __ ] dump it you guys should map that
did I pee so much judging so many fluids
dude it makes me uncomfortable to pee
directly in the water I like to pee on
the side of the toilet you interior
about the silencer - yes silencer yeah I
always use that it could be Australian
so how I'll wake up the whole house it's
so loud oh you'll wake up Whitney's
horses dude she's about seven of them
he's got an endangered species in her
bed but yeah man I just so yeah I go in
there I'll go lightless but if I do I
still even in the dark we'll try to aim
for this space me too between the top of
the toilet and the top of the water you
don't hit a bull's-eye yeah mmm it's
disgusting you know that pees directly
under the water is going to hell
agree oh okay yeah so I'm trying to wear
a nice shirt today with no problem no
you look nice you look nice too
oh they change back look man I'll take a
light beer all right oh I was just gonna
pop off over some bottle surface I'm
here for jazz night alright I got the
evite I'm in band roast here's a
gentleman right here one of the
hard-working frontline workers out there
what's up do
what's up Brendan I got a debate club
for you FedEx or UPS you want that
purple and black hitter or that dirty
brown [ __ ] hey gang buzz buzz gang
bruh
I like what can Brown do for you you
feel me oh yeah when that brown UPS
truck shows up you know you got a nice
fresh package waiting there's nothing
like it man
I love UPS I know UPS has good programs
long terms the people that work over
there I think they got good severance
deals and all of that you know and
residual effects financially but I like
FedEx because I always thought FedEx
should open up a human sapphic until
later human trafficking not trafficking
but dealing yeah well that's what I'm
doing like an airline yeah how great
would it be to fly FedEx because here's
the thing sometimes we be like Oh your
plane's been canceled we can't get you
there for two days you'll be at the
airport but FedEx you could walk across
the street to FedEx and mail something
and it'll be there the next me I can
overnight a package can I just take
FedEx why can't I fly with my package
yeah I'll hold it yeah
let's hold it just put me on the FedEx
play this delivery beef damn I did I'll
tell you what though those UPS guys are
like [ __ ] dressed like in all brown
with their short shorts and their hats
and [ __ ] you got a rep you set yeah yeah
that's a good point and if it look dude
have you ever seen an alligator they are
afraid of the UPS guys but they are not
afraid of the FedEx dude it's matter cuz
of that outfit I think that they get the
Steve Irwin style just a darker Brown
yeah so it's more savage you know I
would love to see you guys fight I would
like to watch you guys fight yeah I
think they should set up some sort of
tough man contest with UPS and FedEx
they do it with cops and firefighters
mm-hmm I'm trying to watch my UPS guy
[ __ ] some people up yeah I wouldn't mind
seeing that man very nice we're building
a whole cart here FedEx for CPS
Chappelle versed
Johnny Curtis yeah you were fighting
someone last episode last week or so
long ago I don't remember what the
Gianni was Johnny no last week boo see
also in its five rounds it's get knocked
out five times to be out I know the deal
is gonna fight Connor at 45 oh yeah with
that cocaine yeah
yeah cocaine in your face oh definitely
I see that's a different story
if it's just you versus Connor straight
up you're gonna lose the only cocaine I
like my eyes yeah two grams of blow dude
I'm taking on duty I might lose but I'll
definitely take him on a Connors legs
home with me yeah I'll chew it off at
the hip dude okay
I'll chew that fricking Irish [ __ ] off
and those two videos were actually just
appetizers is funny that Kat told about
her weekend plans with the Vietnamese
food we've got a bunch of Asian food has
talked about two weeks ago or you got
any bam Chi or what is it I know I know
brendan is absolutely starving so we
can't tell you what it is you have to
call me out like this
we're gonna Brendan's fat ass can't wait
we're gonna my lovely girlfriend Jules
is gonna bring it in I'm gonna help the
Jules girl and we've got four different
types of Asian food
and you guys just tell us what you think
hopefully we can keep the banter up and
the chewing out of the mics and tell us
what you like the best we'll cut it up
if it's too slow for video okay tell you
what I wish we had that Diet Coke what
is this already Asian or not yeah I can
go to Subway and try to claim it the
Asian just cuz its teriyaki on it this
is straight out of Westminster just
where cat went actually it went down
there last night what did you have cat
what was your order I had low from them
BAM yum do don't want that BAM YUM damn
yo is that a real thing are you just
saying it could I have a plate of it boy
that BAM YUM mm-hmm what is this I think
is this cheap sashimi some of us looking
a little suspect up is it all from the
same place there are four different
types of Asian foods a bit at a post man
before I think you guys should take a
guess at what uh what ethnicity each
food is oh wow that's kimchi right don't
yeah you can't don't cheat dudes don't
cheat
I'm right here some kind of freak boy
not someone to get spiked up that
sausage and whatever this is it looks
like seeing a little exotic oh yeah
that's a young lab boy sausage can
always be questionable I think yeah I'm
always super set to a sausage
unless it's coming from Lacey smoking
Lacey's yeah
smoking Lacey's I don't really wash this
down with that diet coke okay I don't
want to okay I'm just teriyaki whatever
it is
oh yeah ass got a little bit of ear lobe
in a nothing case I get it heard
something boy good okay Jen if you were
to pick a Korean food what would you
what would be the dish I mean oh it's
always stick by cream by the original
Korean barbecue you know I mean yeah I'm
scared to try some of it yeah the
sandwich to me looks the most like home
like you said so no like it looks like
Subway you could but it's not that's
authentic you went to a real creator
Asian place for the stuff off all four
of them
Wow mm-hmm that looks good okay
emphasize enough if I had a diet coke I
just texted him I have to fire he's
doing something that sounds is nice Wow
no Nick is there extra mm oh yeah I
believe that might be bull meat this
might be straight bull meat this might
be that Wuhan finest here oh yeah this
had a little bit of good in it yeah that
might be a bat way over there oh yeah
dude that might be that Heath Ledger bra
you feel me I feel you
this thing looks like it has been used
piece east baby I'm a sweet-and-sour
sauce when I see it you feel me
oh you can always dump enough that on
there oh yeah just got this that lamb
gin this is a glam based I think there's
a jam isn't it yeah it's more of a jam
than a sweet and sour sauce
it tastes like somebody freaking it
pulled it out the bottom of a puddle
right here man had some Wow
yeah we get an exotic Oh mmm this that
Street shark right here baby mm-hmm oh
wow there's a thing if I think about
something enough I'm gonna start gagging
if I don't know what it is that's that
all my food baby that sausage has a
weird vibe to it yeah that sausage has
that off micro be like Roby a plague or
something my house like a real yep Oh
God god bless you do you guys just check
out that pet owner vibe too exotic
sausages you have the weird vibe on it
it tastes like somebody wrote if found
on the collar that kidnap here we got
something real wild here at the yeah see
I don't you try it first I'm gonna go
and dive back into this mm-hm me with a
contest Brendan what's the contest to
wit to name which countries are from oh
wow
Brendan is just looking for nourishment
haha dude I'm sorry get the calipers oh
this is game hand baby oh yeah ain't no
hands in Asia brother oh oh yeah Jen do
you already know what they all are
kind of a feeling yeah hello yeah I
don't have a clue that shine wine right
here baby this a rotator cuff out of
song I can feel this things turn the
doorknob or something a little bit you
know yeah this thing is apparently has
some sort of weird gravy I hope you can
taste the torque that thick gravy no I
don't know man
oh yeah dude this is definitely hmm
it's like the rotator cuff my damn
Falcon right here ooh
Thanksgiving hitter you taste it yeah I
don't taste like anything's given I've
ever had
yeah uh no way get in there wow man I
encourage all the audio listeners to go
check out the YouTube this is gonna be
much more enjoyable these are really and
these are different you do you know what
all these dishes are cat or no I can
guess I think I do and this is lamb I
think so there's a good bit of lamb oh
yeah anymore that teriyaki beef you let
me know there's a good bit of adult lamb
we got any beef wore out of beep
whatever mm-hm
exotic zebra that was listen let's take
some guesses what what countries do we
think those are from we got four Asian
countries do we get to know the
countries or we just get I say just
guess okay we can we can air it if you
need mm-hmm okay hmm
I would like to pick her you pick a
country first all right I'll go with
good I'll say cat and chin are both
represented okay I'm gonna go with this
dish here with the kimchi is a Korean
Korean is that the soft it's awesome
wait do we name it and they tell us or
how do we do this both of you guests and
then we'll tell you after okay that's
better
I'm go this this was this is Korean huh
this little batwing here with the gravy
is Chinese oh that's that space lamb
babies that's that dark arts bird also
known as a bat
sooo that's if that's a bad that is the
biggest matter of everything that bad
has a little bit of beagle in it the
sausage I must say Philippines so yes is
[ __ ] go on like sausage I'm gonna say
[Laughter]
and then the sandwich is Chinese people
who give a [ __ ] it's all they are this
is from Taiwanese and then I also rank
them what was your favorite the Korean
dish number one the gravy batwing dead
last the sandwich from Taiwan number two
the sausage from the Philippines
number three and deal okay I'm a roll
with this I'm gonna roll with right here
Mac Korean right there a little Korean
Christmas at a little Korean Christmas
breakfast right there Sam baby sit right
here I'm gonna go with the and that's
gonna be the okay right out the gate now
here is where it gets a little bit oh
that's where it gets a little bit more
herb and you know what I'm saying yeah
straight you can't even troll this plate
man I'm gonna say right here we're
getting into that kind of darker Asian
I'm gonna go with the Pinoy baby I'll go
with Filipinos right there cuz they out
there they got a lot of hold out there
with them
that's like rice this right here dude
this seemed like that duck out of uh
that Christmas duck out of that movie
yes duck bro the duck has uh miss that
duck Christmas ducks they shoot the boy
and I
you know it's like I think it's like
Chicago or something but uh I don't know
I keep referencing Christmas
so Terry argues Christmas dude in that's
Christmas dude it's Sam Christmas I got
four plates of food in front of me man
this is Christmas so this one let me do
you run out ideas huh
yeah me too that's I said Taiwan oh no
no I forgot about this one this one I'm
gonna go with I guess I'll go with
Chinese so Korean Vietnamese Filipino
Chinese I think we said the same thing
yeah y'all doing oh no yeah I know you
go we got something
no is this Chinese all day Brendan said
Korean was Korean and that was his
favorite nailed it he said uh what you
got this wrong we'll see ya
he's at the Filipino food that he ranked
last was Chinese that's chicken adobo
news to me the one that you said was
Philippines the sausage that is Thai
sausage oh I know I was part of Asia
yeah no we're going that that baby I
don't know we're going that global with
it
that's a us you don't well then with
them Russian foods considered a just two
then you know I'm saying dog no rush is
Asia true and finally the Vietnamese
Brendon wet with Taiwanese which is not
represented on our safe lick though I'll
respect that pic now mmm Co got
Vietnamese correct Vietnamese and that's
all that's all he got right there is no
food from Christmas story no he got your
Christmas Korean though oh oh a nice
Christmas Korean breakfast right yeah
yeah so he said the first once you got
to this is Korean yeah okay so I got
Korean and Vietnamese but I did not get
what is this tie tie tie tie sausage no
one got tired mmm and it's also
Philippine
yeah we just switched it up Filipinos to
Pinot Grigio which is a wine I'm a
lounge you've obviously opened up as
soon as the speakeasy is shut that
Filipino food it was the worst oh yeah
oh what is this one oh you know what the
sausage is good I think just to look of
it as a different style of chicken that
I'm not used to hmm it's a lot of dark I
never trust sausage dude as he downed it
I trust rice this got that darkwing duck
in it right here man go get some that
sausage really well we're really good
though this is really interesting about
this sausage because they have the same
stuff in Louisiana they make the same
kind of style sauce is it spicy
sometimes it is that's a very gaming
spice no it has a gamy vibe but they
make that boudin down there and we have
more foods coming that will just be
dessert it was supposed to be our fifth
ethnicity our ubereats Panda Express
delivery guy cancelled and then they're
gonna be late so well Thank You Jules
thank you calling for help and provide
this Thank You Nick guys thanks running
the jewels yeah
Canton jewels were uh they were double
teaming what what kind of food we're
gonna have there they're texting about
it no one texted me and he said some
venom II [ __ ] and I was like that's not
him so what do you think there's I
wonder what it is cuz do do Vietnamese
people like American food a lot or no
some do like my mom really won't touch
any American food my dad's super into
American food your mom won't touch it no
poison no she just doesn't like it she
thinks it's too sugary too fatty
delicious who salty too much of
everything yeah that's fair I could see
that yeah she doubles down on bean buys
though huh there's bean pies are pretty
good it's definitely an acquired taste
though I can't believe you guys it makes
it no orange chicken from Panda they
tried but yeah it's it's gonna show up
late but you do have orange chicken
coming it was gonna be like the
punchline
to his Chinese and also up or half a
chaste on morons - I'll rub my body with
double orange chick oh I feel like [ __ ]
afterwards yeah you do you know what I
keep saying that but I don't I'm pretty
happy after I really like yeah I don't I
feel like things are never gonna work
out that's I I don't feel great after
this really yeah I feel like there's a
war in my stomach
a civil war that's gonna come out oh no
you'll be fine man your reenactment
[Laughter]
really good know what's good this this
this I just like when it's wet I can't
[ __ ] with it man we mix wet and Asian
food I'm not messing with it it's just
braised chicken it's braised chicken aw
it's not though that's that soy that's a
thick man gravy it's braised man try it
Chappelle its braised chicken Brendan I
don't like the way you talk about is
they don't make me what I don't you can
see the skit like though this is like
it's chicken I don't know brother what
do you think's in a chicken dude just
think you want all kind of stuff in
there you got to get out man or get in
or did you barely ate yours I ate as
much as I could man I'll try to get to
the different plates so I could try
everything mm-hmm jo koy would be so
upset with you all I know yeah I'm gonna
tell him I tried it it's not for me I'm
gonna tell him you Hilux man everybody
always trying to stay at my house all
the time because that's because you got
that Hilux baby and helix helix is the
way to sleep they have a quiz that takes
just 2 minutes to complete and matches
your body type and sleep preference to
the perfect mattress for you so you're
not going you're not just laying down
all willy-nilly on some rectangle you
know damn with you so rested oh you look
well brah think you don't need to take
their word for it hilux was awarded the
number one best overall mattress of 2019
and 2020 by GQ and Wired magazine I'm
talking specific matches for everybody's
unique body men just go to helix sleep
calm /k ATS take the two minutes sleep
quiz and the match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of yo live that's right take your
warranty baby your warranty all ten
years man you can sleep for ten years if
you ain't ready to leave your house mmm
you could they have a 10-year warranty
you get to try it out for a hundred
nights risk-free like Charlie and
chocolate factors grandma grandpa
yep do 90 nights do 90 nights and then
decide how you feel they'll even pick it
up for you if you don't love it but you
will helix is offering up to $200 off
all mattress orders and free pillows for
our listeners at helix hg l IX
sleep dot-com / k 80s that's helix sleep
comm / k 80s for up to $200 off go sleep
right now here's a guy right here knows
what's up oh yeah like this tattoo is
definitely looks like the outtakes the
eastbound and down Brendan do coming at
you from the great state of Maine got
like four days of summer up here close
so we're celebrating the king of
sticking for you that king of the sting
suit
grass clippings and all redneck good
times great shades inflatable pool as a
kid they're so fun if somebody had an
inflatable pool man that [ __ ] was live
right we thought they're rich
dude when I live in South Carolina and
Charleston they had this dude mr. Larry
he was like the landlord or whatever and
we just thought he was like some [ __ ]
guy that bothered us you know and on
this place had like three stories in the
top story had like a little porch and we
bought a wet pool what is it called wet
inflatable inflatable pool yeah and put
it out there on the porch and spills a
water whoo like a wet pool hmm so then
we all sat in it - we're sitting like
and literally the
in the wall in the kitchen is cracking
because we didn't think that we're
putting all this water it took like 25
minutes to fill it up oh yeah I was on
the top of the kitchen on this like a
little patio and uh it costs about six
thousand dollars everything and dude
look he was out from the ground he
looked up at us and saw us all because
it was either you're swimming or you
guys are not straight guys this is still
a time and it was just kind of wild you
just had come out of the closet from the
third story of a building with to your
friends you go
and so we're like nope so dude he comes
storming in the apartment you can hear
him going up the different Louis and
we're literally push the side down and
just floating all this water and he
busted a man in the whole kitchen wall
crack today's portable pools slip and
slide oh I love the above-ground pool
and dad where pretend he was getting
like in the deep end what now you know
and then mom would leave mom me boy that
bomb us but I like it Civil War skin
that's what else we got here this
lesbian fight
[Laughter]
I've got a king what's this question one
bedroom studio apartments all your own
air conditioning his wife is this small
also everything that they showed after
you said UFC fight pass got funnier
thank you he's cracking a beer did I
thought that was this corner girl man up
Mike Barry you have the new mic very
training ya installing your own AC I
like it look you got to stay cold man
anything that gets that cold air in
there like a swamp cooler I remember
when I was a kid my buddy Joey Sinead
Ewell had a swamp cooler that things
happen dude wasn't cuz we even have
regular AC so he's had that swamp cool
mmm-hmm I don't know but I remember when
we were like at night mama put the AC
down about two degrees you know so you
had to prep for that [ __ ] you know so
as soon as she cut that [ __ ] down you
had like it was like a time clock like I
better [ __ ] go to sleep right now you
know while that cold air was flowing and
we would go get some cold water out of
the sink and put it on our bed on that
sheet and it would just be real cold you
know lay on that sucker bro yeah just be
hot out this is Louisiana just got hot
as hot at night so I like it man
anything you can do to get that cold air
inside you know or just pretend if you
don't do it at least pretend it's cold
trick the kid you know put ice on the
kids neck tape ice on it's cold in here
and it keep telling them it's cold yeah
yeah he's like damn there's some real
hot cold
oh well man you don't know Brian II
ain't doing [ __ ] mean about [ __ ] so dang
beautiful little daughter both those key
boat the kids wearing bees this time of
year
knees up knees up when you say bees up
that's a blood thing so yeah dude you
almost killed last episode we got all
these emails oh listen
Kings can't claim everything I can't say
bees up mister all right and there's no
more what are these gangs doing the rep
inert they don't have own any real
estate they're always like claiming
these [ __ ] neighborhoods
yeah they don't everyone just Retton
yeah
did they claim that Street you know yeah
so we're bringing back after popular man
cats in the wild evidently Theo has been
at a rave the left is DJ boosted [ __ ]
dance with the people there's intense
and there's not that many people that
clubs that that has college if some of
those college later the party in the
state yeah like in the convention and
we're all the college things that would
have come see this guy do magic know
some guy's wife is leaving him memory
clubs they have on college campuses
every club you ever [ __ ] imagine they
get together it'll be like four of them
hmm last week we talked about how much
Brendan loved Jerry Springer
and that's why he one day fulfilled his
dream and he was on dr. Phil
[Music]
process of Starbucks coffee forget my
eyelashes done eyebrows make sure I'm
put together I'm on point what it takes
to bad Mooji oh my bad in my lifestyle
that I have I will steal from my family
and just clothes me since I was a baby
so I kind of still expect that at 26 I
do go shopping on my own but like I said
affected some of my mom's money before
my money than I will in the past three
years I've probably stolen about twenty
to twenty-five thousand dollars from my
mom I've stolen between three to five
thousand from my sister when I steal I
get a rush this one time I stole for my
friend she was at work at the time and
she would leave her cash at home she
literally had like three or four grand
honored I just started to cash out of
the purse if I can take somebody else's
money to build myself up then I'm going
to I have to have the money to make
myself look as a burglar for a guy I
know I am a good worker I got a little
bit of an ass so it's like let me show
what guys gave me it's four minutes of
this Barney how did conclude stop
stealing no he didn't dude we don't have
this not well this is still going on
there was that was Hollywood where he
was down in we need to send one this got
a one Allison change concert you know
yeah that'd be great even amount no Inch
Nails concert girl he's stealing yeah
that's my world right there mosh pits
your big ass in mosh pits oh yeah little
kids
we're down who were you were you that
battering ram or you were you more the
referee and we're taking care kids yeah
I'll take care of everybody line side
like that movie The Blind Side yeah I
got sucked in a job by 15 year old one
time that [ __ ] hurt why'd he punch you
it would be just motion is that a penny
wise console we were just like it was a
big ass circle pit what was the song
girl and what song were they playing at
the time he was [ __ ] 30 oh yeah
that'll do it man they thought I was
Authority I'm just damn yeah don't worry
Wilson or something Authority and uh
chin
he's been moonlighting on the side
behind her backs
[Laughter]
[Music]
scale it says don't do something we
can't hear it
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
girl behind the player tambourine oh
yeah that's kimchi right to this life is
over oh don't shoot
this was two weeks ago in Big Bear yeah
there's a small bass on the bass think
that gun the bass isn't really playing
all they need is you should fell out
from mosh damn that guy's terrible huh
well this is socialism man what kind of
agent are they huh
look Filipino they look so you know yeah
yeah but it could be something else and
Filipinos really love to get up there on
the microphone okay oh yeah and what is
it about the aging it what Asian culture
likes to get up on the microphone the
most no this is something all Koreans
there's a ton of Craner entertainers but
I don't know if they like like it the
most no no what I think karaoke the
first thing I think of is oh yeah
but as far as like talent goes bright
Korea right Koreans and Filipinos I
think yeah well as far as musical time
singing yeah yeah
and we actually someone found a picture
of Chapelle at she let's me
let me guess her name I loved oh yeah is
it Beth
no Tiffany no Stephanie no Kimmy no kami
Kelly no Rachel no Monica I think your
name starts with L Lauren no Larissa
Lisa no Linda I thought you'd rather say
right there
the Lin's be Leslie Lin Lindsay Lindsay
the lesbian those first days that's like
first and like you all up on that
backhand rest looks like he he hasn't
made up his mind whether he wants to
guess we should bring in some dances
some of my pictures when we went to
dances I'm sure my mom and dad yeah you
got to get a few I got some yeah
dan where did somebody find this she
said it to me
Wow while a girl well they used to hook
me up I was always the guy who got
hooked up with a friend that didn't have
a date you know okay lesbians because
they figured you got to hit it off it
was anybody there like Oh we'll hook
them up with the big st. big Samantha or
something or you know your likes at all
yeah low back or something you know
little risky you know little rusty
Ramona get a little Ronny all right no
Ronnie's bored so I don't always get the
date I always be like that ninth wheel
you know that service that uh you know
that small-time and what's lesbian Linda
do these days it's Lena what's she do
huh dude teacher that's cool yeah she's
Dan you think kind of like a ton of
people for you yeah do you yeah man not
a lot of not a lot of I do it no I don't
know
hell yeah do you Nick uh when I go back
home I see them but it's like we're not
talking daily do I look like Jacob
Hester he played football for a while
LSU fall back pull them up that's what
you look like
I think so
yeah yes yeah he's a stud he got in
trouble though right
no he didn't no he's a good man who the
mauler the Chargers right yeah you got
to get his helmet off him nothing there
you go huh
no yeah you're right with this you don't
think right now hold on oh hell yeah boy
he's a stud
praise God I look like number 57 over
there Wow damn that is you huh looks
like Jacob Astor stayed out of trouble
yep but save mega to see you're thinking
of know you keep saying all these other
people it's either Dave Meggitt or it's
that guy from Indianapolis who shot
people at a car wash no Marvin Harrison
Marvin Harrison
who gets no credit that's classical
Buress gets all the credit
Aaron Hernandez all these other guys a
tour I'm says nothing about starving
starvin Marvin first of all owned a car
wash which I totally respected with on
my ideal business as ever to have it be
a car wash so let's do it yourself and
then he gunned a guy down there at it
you know who else got started in car
washes Lenny Dykstra did he really
I loved car washes man I like I want to
get the coins out the box get there put
the things in there for the sprayers I
love it I love washing my car what the
[ __ ] is this Nick we this one really
doesn't have a segment but who cares
young or some what did I have dude one
of these things tasted a little young
one of these things tasted a little you
know let's think that's a little
premature bro like that it co were stood
out the egg you know we gave the
Chesapeake Crippler a couple weeks ago
some career advice I want to do as a
wrestler reset maybe go gay
and someone sent this in and we might be
like okay like Mark Irish smart that's
the same with you Alice how about it's
finished just by now that's what I call
UFC heavy on the air this is more this
is almost sex you Alice that rear naked
choke is little different meaning with
these boys grow heavy on the naked we
all know what the C stands for
Wow
we should get in that link oh just one
match dude you you could do it where are
they then boys oh dude dude yeah we
could have a big finishing move you I
jump off your shoulders yeah I'll be
cool and you just you like Yokozuna and
drop on him with that ass yeah yeah I
don't want to bite my dick
dude you gotta keep your dick you gotta
you gotta fight harder [ __ ] bro you got
a tight nut man bro this is America it
was real heavy on the key this is the
valiance was our dad's name Richie did
those people go like you know those
people go there and see a regular
wrestling eat the other guy's dick in
the car like but talk about a finishing
move bro you go here and somebody
[Laughter]
they're all taking the under dude all
right here's some guy right here is my
deep in homeboy leaving his wife and
kids in the middle of the night those
guys are off I thought those the one guy
that's about driving parking we did
though I think this guy might be a
different guy unless I got to what up
King in this thing
this is Brennan from Lafayette Louisiana
all right we could do it again and
pretend we do with different answers
we're gonna split I can get wrestling
the whole time that's hilarious
yeah even a dick
what I need a nap you don't happy boo oh
there's a steep ravine debate club
the sand lob or The Mighty Ducks
it's tough I don't think one of the
medium-rare ducks I know that there's
nothing about the sandlot huh well the
same lot as children what is it children
don't have they don't know what's going
on they don't have a team and so they
get a team together
well neighborhood team and they play and
then they play against another team like
best friends and then the neighbor has
like a scary dog and hit the ball over
there mm yeah they talk about the great
Bambino oh yeah Sandlot destroys Mighty
Ducks bless that muck Mighty Ducks
goalie your memories like addicted to
meth oh [ __ ] man have you seen oh yeah
dad goalies a tough position man ah cues
watch of rich kids Hawks a bunch of rich
kids like yeah yeah wow that's a goalie
yeah I think he's stopping at some
[ __ ] meth in his veins you feel me
mm-hmm that's meth oh yeah my bean you
always all that weight without a get on
some meth he was also in the classic
heavyweights Oh Ben Stiller mm-hmm
wonder what happened to he was such a
charming young guy you know I think grew
up in like drugs
you think yeah he was trying to meet
Connor and Theo at 145 he could use
manscaped I know that uh you know not to
say everybody could use it but he could
also use it that's not even him on the
right that's a different guy but that's
an alien on the right on Weiss mugshot
he was getting better though maybe he's
better now yeah he goes getting but a
little better hockey no was he back
playing hockey do we know I don't know
dude he probably is going on he probably
got offsides in his veins dude I hope
he's yeah yeah it's tough that's icing
bro is everybody cool on the Sandlot I
think so yes I one time met squeaks and
the red-haired kid on the streets of
Minneapolis really they were touring MLB
stadiums and like
showing the sandlot I gotta find this
picture that's kind of depressing too
but still Patrick Rinna is the redhead
dudes named
though the one guide the guy who would
go for ever he was in the logic video
mm-hmm 2 Chainz well I think to change
was then it wasn't he
well guys it's a it's like the dead of
summer right now then they feel weird
and that crazy
this is dead of some summer's lip yeah
pools two kids swimming up in Maine and
that's the only thing that's even going
on this summer we're summer ever
just feel so ashamed of myself well it's
not your fault brother you're right bro
you can thank the government yeah here's
a guy was in the military right here
what up Brendan got a debate club for
you guys today
robbing banks who would you rather have
beef with OJ Simpson or that Beach care
of by asking remember they both got away
with murder allegedly on Carole Baskin
would rather have beef with gang gang
lick butts
that's tough one I'm less worried about
Carole Baskin I'm not trying to touch
those Tigers I'm never gonna go to the
zoo Oh chase everywhere dog oh he's out
here he's in Vegas yeah Florida oh yeah
he's giving you coming comments on
[ __ ] Instagram and Twitter
he gave me a eulogy somewhere it's
somebody's funeral dearly eulogy are you
you are Carol just well Carol's low-key
right now because also Carol screwed
everybody Carol's a businesswoman though
now I will say that
you know she took over that uh yeah the
the [ __ ] zoo and I'm sure exotics she
took over the zoo but apparently PETA
called because the lines are covered in
maggots and flies oh my oh my it's
getting risky man Wow
I don't know bro I look if I had two
arrows bro
I'd shoot him at both them [ __ ]
honestly dawg yeah I mean OJ's turning
like a character almost of himself but
he's out there playing golf yeah you
know I killed a woman or knew somebody
that did he definitely did it yeah got
somebody to do that convicted in civil
court I didn't realize he still gets
money from know they they garnish his
wages it all goes to the Nicole Brown
family oh wow I don't know how I don't
know how he's living there they're doing
it somehow to know somehow hello hello
yeah well how about we how about he on
Twitter talking about look at you Nick
Wow
you boys a little too close to each
other damn mix up his long ass arms too
friendly I was excited man you guys do
some wrestling after this we were like
squeeze come up and drink with us or
come out and drink with us he's like no
I'm the girls up in the room and I gotta
leave and he bounced and then the other
guy went home by himself the other guy's
name is Patrick Rinna where was this at
um streets of Minneapolis like a 2014
damn they do the sound sandlot - I
actually thought yeah I think Santa 3
was even a thing really mm-hmm
DVD [ __ ] don't stop yeah yeah men boys
just never gave up on San lolly they
wrote that [ __ ] the wheels fell a lot
and drop it dog what's that girl look
like that he made out with at the pool
Oh Winnie peppercorn yeah or AB burn
what's she looking like now she passed
away oh she Liddy like a titty yeah dude
give me a tea Tim Marley show Marley
show yeah well that she's the only one
doing well damn bro
she's still killing it that's Mindy
straight-up theft for corn dude mm-hmm
hide me and them tits got a home run
baby hide and go tits yeah whoa
y'all go hard I'll count two tits you
feel oh she's still not sorry
yeah that's out of line that's out of
line yeah she's a man hunt write or die
dirty John he's an actress yeah you
right she went hard meshes and stops he
kept going yeah good for her she don't
let sandlot to find her like the other
boys the other boy just never moved on
well so collecting baseball cards and
[ __ ] you know it's interesting to know
the clubhouse to know how that kind of
stuff works out I guess did you ever
audition for any movies or anything Kat
or acting I came here for theater school
and then right when I graduated I was
like hey maybe not hmm but I started
working on the podcast instead so that's
great would you say majoring in theatre
was a complete waste of time
no only because I needed to get out of
San Jose I would have stayed in San Jose
if I didn't you could have been in gang
get been in pregnancy you think you
would enjoy the game no but you could
imagine anything you could wanted the
accountant for a gang or something
that's what I want to look like I want
to look like I work for HR in a game
like that well you've done that I could
see that I could see on like a kill bill
kind of being like a yeah look at what
I'm saying you don't use theater at all
right now so now majors in something
else
mmm I could have but I don't think I
would have showed up to class if I'm
being completely honest hmm and what
would you have been doing instead um
drugs chilling no I probably actually
I'd probably be a drug dealer I'd just
be a pharmacist yeah there's a joke
about Vietnamese people always being
drug dealers
you sell illegally or you become a
pharmacist yes Vietnamese person on the
first 48 the other day I thought about
you guys I like it and I don't man
daliyah has the best okey said that
first 48 you have 48 hours to solve the
murder but really you have as much time
as you want
never solve it in 48 no and they put the
clicker at the bottom I think alright I
don't care like six months later yeah we
got guys just working on this you know
barbecue joint damn trying to add James
up you know I got mapping it out you
know typing it up on my computer
see it might be were help you still
watch that food truck we might invest
share the Pels Oh waste sauce wheels
baby no look it shove on that T on the
TF ATK site that picture is oh you know
what that's from when I worked for the
UFC for ESPN you mean enterprise you did
something
I was over I wish I did do someone's an
analyst for ESPN for I was on sport as a
host for Sports feeling yourself no I'm
pointing at the pink it's a 24 karat
gold finding the kid pin someone made it
for me I don't know man I think you yeah
respective Rose one of the top card
companies man shut up my boy Bobby Keys
up there in the Northeast region needs
to run it up there that's it man there
you go
you gonna skate in that shirt Oh skate
right into the speakeasy they go right
into work lounge baby they're pajama top
bears meet me at more ninety-day huh
zoom out they get Stefan in the purple
there if you zoom out on the pictures Oh
fans found step onto Instagram will you
actually send that picture to step on it
see what he says about it I've been
ignoring my advances let's be seeing
someone
[Laughter]
yeah what are you doing at the Grammys
hosting the pre-show for it really damn
man hey I got I would give my lounge off
the ground okay yeah so support that
thing I want to work this out that
cigarette your person that walks around
the cells of cigarettes in the gum oh
you do that for me yeah I'll be the the
bathroom attendant with the meds
there you go see I need that what some
boys drop them turds dude I had a guy
one time I go in there in the bathroom
right they got a guy in there
right when I go in there we're doing
number two stressful he goes I got your
back bro you know like why and I'm like
how much does this cost
I don't need any help right then
[ __ ] escalate so somebody comes in and
they start kind of poem load or somebody
that really has to go to the bathroom
right and the guy once thought what's up
and the guys like whoa man that's my boy
in here I never seen this guy bro so the
guy pulls in the door again he's like I
said this my [ __ ] boy dog and he
[ __ ] push them and people are getting
peed around me I can't do poop dude I
was in see I was north of Seattle at
they sent a comedy club up there and it
wasn't in Bellevue it was somewhere out
there that a mall out there or something
they put you up put you in a nice hotel
they had a comedy club
hey I trying take a [ __ ] in there I had
to I think it was anybody around there
and I guess had a party or something
going on the other side of it it was
like a Dave & Buster's
[Laughter]
yeah reminds you being young bro kind of
[ __ ] while my siblings are always
getting beat
you can't do it and I'll never do it
again and therefore you had no choice
yeah these are my poop dude taking them
back I'm taking them all back there's
nothing more stressful in the bathroom
attendant bro what you need I got you
man I got you dog turns on the water I
got the water man just another good
story that one time I'm in Radford
University it did a college show over
there and so met some kids afterwards
and they had two guys are on the
basketball team and so went out and
party with them after the show and it
was fun we had a nice time literally the
week after when one of them hit like a
75-foot Iran on it was like on the ESPN
like their top highlights but anyway
fast forward two weeks later I am in
UCLA at one of the bars and I'm in I'm
downstairs I'm in the bathroom and the
guy and the guy who played on the
basketball team in Radford had like an
African accent like I don't know what
country in Africa but and so the guy
working in the bathroom was a black guy
who had an African accent and I said oh
you sound like this kid that I met her
at this this this basketball player cuz
I was kind of excited I've met some
basketball guys yeah and he goes oh my
son plays basketball Oh Jen I was like
oh yeah and he's like yeah Radford
Radford University [ __ ] and he pulled
out a picture he had a picture of his
son like some printed out and it was the
same kid this kid it was crazy bro don't
work there anymore they probably got
changed it was a real [ __ ] it wasn't a
shady place but it was like I mean
people were [ __ ] in like the parking
lot [ __ ] I was one of them but if I look
outside of myself people were doing
but he was a nice guy man what's the
chance it was crazy dude and you had a
picture of me I was like no way that's
him I said I met your sound like two
weeks ago
that's great bathroom attendants do that
I see him I get stressed [ __ ] here we go
some of them yeah some of them I love
them though a nice to smoke cigarettes I
get that you about one cigarette all
right Lucy yeah god bless them smoke
cigarettes too Nick no I watch your pal
show yeah but yeah you could get that
man if you needed a mint and always have
the nice mints - yeah the white one yeah
yeah you get a mint you get a little
hair clip
you get a little yeah cologne to get
around yeah something you have condoms
do you really and if you take yourself
outside of them I'm one of the people
doing it so oh man thank you guys for
making the making this food and bringing
it in yeah it was great this is cool
yeah and thank you guys so much for
supporting the podcast that's the
lecture pail with the new endeavor
everybody's ready to buy it once you get
it going good luck with your fishing
Thank You Nick good luck with your bets
thank you thank you weeks dude July 11th
oh yeah who is this Saturday
who is it three title fights you spin
verse Gilbert burns ciao yeah Volk
Vulcan ops an auskey Holloway max
Holloway and then you got waily waily
verse what pull up the carros no no no
just gone Josh Rose is fading and Raj
you're right
Oh Peter yang Jose Aldo oh yeah that's
great fight
oh wow then yeah just good Whaley
Patriots finance do you think it's safe
running for all these fighters to be
coming back so so a lot of people seem
like they're come back really quick from
fights
I just think guys are boards at home
they're trying to get pay cause it you
know they can't make money right now
yeah yeah yeah that's a good point and
it a great card though yeah wow this is
my underdog pick Yuri port rasca oh yeah
it's plus 1/16 plus one is not bad bet
what kind of [ __ ] though yeah
there you go Nick's giving one away this
week next week it'll be his patreon you
better get me there last week you won
eight grand so so what is your bet
against me and Johnny Curtis
wrestler man I think you're gonna be
it's gonna be up against cage three
rounds not gonna be good it's gonna be a
boring fight and he's gonna 30-27 yeah
3027
maybe thirty twenty six there anything
that's saying yeah that's nicely saying
yeah I give you the 26 all right man
we'll see you guys next week man hey
guys
Brennan and Theo fighter and wait I
gotta go in and go hard in the paint I
do not think
and flows like rifle coffee I'm ready to
go I need a sponsor I am a monster about
to open up with visit my concerts PO is
contagious browser outrage is thicker
than girls leather Instagram famous damn
like I'm fresh off keto see a red like
Andrew Santino right every Sunday is
like the great Bambino gonna take the
case oh and a case Cerritos but
everything's gonna be fine
hate on me I do not mind got a pack of
matches in his pockets at all times
they sliding into my DMS a couple of you
try but couldn't beat him quit playin
like Nintendo DS you don't want the
smoke like Joey Diaz meaning y'all
edible just got my eyebrows threaded and
I'm feeling incredible grit and Sun him
me up he said it's too loud in the club
can you pick me up a sting
and the sting bee sting Rat King
in a stinky nasty
truck got that cheese on a string
the sting king in the sting King in the
sting bee sting crack king
the sting okay and instinct of bees in
the truck got that cheese on a string
[Music]